[Music]
this is like a Joe Molly and am I the
[ __ ] all right okay so Jamie joy
Gibson here says from the citizens of
timaeus for the citizens of John Mallia
she says am i wrong for wanting 200 of
my room and board refrain from college
which is about less than a little less
than 2,000 to buy a switch light rather
then give it all to my parents for bills
by the way I am a senior in college so
all senior activities including
graduation has been canceled who was
paying for it before who paid for the
room and boy was it her parents oh I'm
her pretty sure it's our parents all
right then it goes back to your parents
I don't know I'm just guessing right but
but get us which light they'll get the
switch because then TV yeah what's the
difference between the light in the
switch you can't take out the
controllers so although one you can
remove the controller as a name if you
play together and you can't plug it in
the TV so the light is more like like a
big game boy it's just completely talk
to your parents I can use can they spare
that tone as always is it immediate
funds that they need because Berle in
this whole pandemic thank your parents
hey gang at $300 gonna like switch lives
first don't want to go to paying bills
oh it's boring so she should need it if
the parents really freaking nudists and
what they need it for or they should do
you think she should just give it to him
I think she should give it back yeah
yeah yeah it's their money
yeah but what is she gonna do during
this time during quarantine she ain't
got [ __ ] to do she get a job by her own
switch light that's exactly what you
have so many friends start businesses
that help people because of the
quarantine through that like I have one
friend that started all restaurants like
help fuel feed creating food like that's
cheap because people can't afford that
much and she goes and preps and
everything that should deliver and
everything so I'm like that's just don't
like people are and she's not because
that she's also making resourceful yes
it's like when you don't have something
to entertain yourself you end up
creating things that create is it
difficult from scratch to make $200 no
well is it difficult right now I think
28 million people are unemployed so but
like that's what I was trying to give in
are some advice in our podcast they
don't tell you but when I was talk about
money house
be very mindful about how a lot of
people have been laid off right now but
there are like if you need $200 and I'm
not talking about being able to pay your
whole rent so if that's like something
that's that's [ __ ] up it sucks but but
like when you need an extra $200
there are so many jobs on like Fiverr or
like online jobs where you can the only
$40 an hour to type captions for videos
like there's so much there's so much you
can do online work from home if you need
a couple hundred dollars is it feasible
is sustainable for the long term no no
but if you need a hundred dollars right
now you can do it it's in your room yeah
yeah I feel like $2,000 should go if
your parents paid for it it should go
back to them I mean we're at the same
time even what if I worked and I paid
$2,000 and I got that back my refund if
my parents need it right now to pay the
bills to pay rent to pay I would do it I
would give it to them because how am I
gonna charge my Nintendo if the
electricity is out yeah but if she gives
the money to her parents they're just in
buy groceries she's just bored and poop
it out yeah or if she spends the $200
she could make five hundred thousand
bells with like a thousand Turner died
from hunger just a thousand Turner
return on investment much higher oh she
could sell her switch because switches
are the [ __ ] demand right now
probably will sell that [ __ ] for like
three times what it's worth right now so
she buys it for 200 and then sells
herself on dough and then buy another
one yeah my another switch sells it
again but then give that money that she
made back to her parents that's where
one of my friends did in college is he
got he wanted like a Apple like MacBook
right so he did remember iPods yeah he
resembled fun iPods an era and he grew
it he grew the money to the point where
he bought a MacBook from it beautiful
he's had friends that stole I pod and
sold them benefit count
his business does count I read about
people who would buy an item and then
they would slowly over time sell it for
a little bit more itself a little bit
more and they buy something else that
was worth a little bit more and they
work all the way up the [ __ ] line
buying boats one day because I can't do
that I need something that's like at
least double the cause I can't do it
like say five by seven for 100 I can't
sell for like a hundred fifty you know
that's slow slow but that is a way
though and my buddy did that if you
could do that and that's a business of
yours that's what teaches their business
as they go to so then they get way
better at it by the time they're selling
the speedboat the learning experience
yeah it's a cool lot of trading the good
old fashioned we like just our
eliminates dead mm-hmm I got a lot of
lemons people trust a lot of foot
traffic these days they're delivering
well like for me if I need a money right
now I could look up what's in my room
that people need well you can tell a
sock huh you could tell listen no but
like say like I got someone wants to buy
a ps4 they can't buy or whatever it's
super expensive right say I want a
laptop
okay I'm gonna sell my ps4 for cheaper
or whatever I'll still get money out of
it right can I could do that for a few
of us it's all your sperm good right now
yeah Kolbe it smells like $50 that's it
yeah it's a lot more for eggs can make
like ten thousand with it
and I'm just giving them away every
month is it I'm down well you got you at
them I think this is a great time for
Jamie to learn how to make 200 bucks
yeah just being creative yeah this is
gonna teach it to the challenge I
challenge you to go make $200 yeah you
could do this without only fans only
fans to say hey we got no judge before
all new fans people send us those links
please do we have Jamaa means that our
only fans girls really yeah dude you
make so much money
who why do people keep telling Joe he
would make so much money on all new fans
leave the poor guy alone he doesn't want
a jerk-off you guys would I would say
like between fifty one hundred thousand
dollars you guys yeah fifty to a hundred
thousand probably every month like that
once people see your dead body take a
screenshot it and then just lead us to
them
I feel like that I feel like the ratio
of people value yeah I like working dumb
and like slowly getting more subscribe
to my only fans what are some other ways
someone can make money right now like
even their clothes is Jamie yeah like
people that want to help the family or
just buy something on their own so
selling old clothes create a website
create a website research marketing get
foot traffic and affiliate you can get
affiliate dollars for putting ads on
your what's up Philly 'lt dollars
affiliate marketing is like when you
have those ads on the side of a website
or a banner ad and people click on it
it's like you don't even a foot traffic
though cuz like you need foot traffic
that's why I said as I said research
marketing so you go do a Facebook ad and
it will cost you maybe some money to do
the Facebook ad but then so I guess you
still need to make money this weekend
we're gonna scrap there's got a skill
work on something that people would hire
you for cuz even if you didn't make
money off of the ads on your website you
now know how to build a website so now
if you build a website for someone you
can put that on your resume but just
like when you don't have money you you
should be learning a skill or craft and
then you will make more money or just
don't buy a switch right but that is
probably gonna keep you from making more
money yeah that could be an incentive to
make money that's the incentive right
like that's it but then it's it's good
because it does teach you you got bills
to pay it doesn't sound like she's like
bored of her parents bills she has zero
money she was in school it sounds like
it what sounds like she's a full-time
student yeah and she was being you know
she was living and now she's not gonna
live you know she's getting a room and
board refund because they paid for the
semester right so she gets that back
right now because she was in college she
might have gone to students checked
because I know what they didn't give
that to college students don't get it
but you can still get unemployment and
if your parents claim is dependent you
cannot even if you were never employed
exactly oh yeah unemployment it just
college students are [ __ ] man yeah cuz
if you're a dependent you're not getting
the stimulus check yeah your and if you
never worked
you're not like a career you're not
getting unemployment but at least you
get to live with your parents who are it
sounds like they're paying us but aside
from just her I'm talking about everyone
at home right now like there's fiber
that's a pretty cool site they have been
do little gigs if you know another
language you could you could you know
you're still doing going around
postmates you're still going around when
I was when I needed to make fast cash
before I actually did those survey
things you know I was like get paid
money for doing surveys I [ __ ] did
that and it takes a while it's not ideal
for making a lot of money but I needed a
couple hundred dollars and I did that
did you feel not in earnest did you just
fill bubbles in and this was back in
like this was like 15 years or so you
could get paid to do surveys you can do
to do surveys and to do like signing up
for trials and then make sure you cancel
in time and stuff so I had a spreadsheet
going of all the things I needed to
cancel and win and like I would just
sign up for things call numbers and I
got paid like $200 for that week and
it's a hustle but and it's not like it's
tedious it's not worth it I'm definitely
not passionate about it but if I wanted
$200 there's always a way there's always
a way I go to Craig's craigslist and
ebay if I need money like especially now
I think those two things are really hot
because Craigslist not so much anymore
it's pretty hot right now cuz of the
quarantine that's been I think you stoke
whatever you need but there's there's
apps especially I think a lot of girls
mostly user where you put like all your
old clothes so this kind of price right
I think you do it too right
so you do that you could go buy that you
could go through your closet everyone
has clothes that they don't need right
that ugh who might do and then they
don't want to spend that much money on
it so you saw to them you go right at
house find random coins I know your
parents might have coins and little jars
here and just taking money back from my
parents yeah but for them for them it's
just an icky jar that they might not
like about a few pennies or quarters
just finally scrounge around the house
right there's other things that you can
look in your room day isn't necessity
they don't use anymore that you can
still sell that stuff for someone they
might want that ask your parents what is
the junk that you need to get rid of and
you can sell it on eBay or Craigslist
because for those other people they
don't have access to buying right now
because wrong quarantine or it's
quadruple the price
or whatever because everyone's trying to
buy units are sold out or they can buy
toilet paper and hand sanitizer get a
lot of it go and then sell it or if you
want to do some classier [ __ ] where you
can get paid to do relatively easy work
if you're a chick you can just like
where all your clothes and then start
sitting on balloons and then film
yourself doing that dude I was just I
was watched a tick talked about this
girl who but made a bunch of money I'm
selling feet pics and she's like it's
really tight because no one ever sees
her face or whatever and she gave actual
websites of where like like the foot
fetish guys go to find feet chicks and
she's like yeah I seriously make
hundreds of dollars I have some nice you
have some nice female thank you she's
like this is how I became a foot their
black underneath about you sold nudes
I've sold nude nude ways me why are you
trying to make geo think about your dick
but so the first one I told wasn't real
the second why did I didn't went you
fraud it somebody you defrauded them yes
you sold someone else you there was
someone else's dick pic yeah yeah
someone else's should have given them a
commission maybe but then after that if
it's a point someone because then people
then they heard that story and they were
like just Louie it's so funny because a
lot of guys write and they're like did
we want nudes they just want you in your
a picture of you in your underwear
no I send me a thousand other way [ __ ]
it just up so you're saying two dudes
you know with this [ __ ] sick dude do
they just DM you and Satan team I'll pay
you a thousand right now just send me a
picture of you and your underwear yeah
yeah I could show you ones like right
now you did tell you what kind of
underwear - where do we have a thousand
dollars is here now is it sexy though
are you just kind of like they reply do
they say you do they say you are a bad
boy or anything no no tell you like how
much to pull that off
yeah I feel like I kind of just in case
like it does leak it's not that max I'm
in my underwear if I kind of want to be
a little hard ish it doesn't look hard
but it makes it look bigger so if it
does people like oh that's dope you know
you should be Harnish for guys and girls
equal you hope we're not that many girls
hit me up the girls would pay
it's always guys that are ya looking for
that so you try to be half artist for
the dudes versatile dudes all for the
deuce it's so funny because then I'm
like I told him I'm 98 and then they're
like yeah I mean we care for girls
lesbian if she's hot and what is being
attracted to feed make you like is that
gay or is that straight we don't know it
they just like feet feet a genin for
[ __ ] or some man feed out there
though even on chicks yeah I got the
Hobbit feet yeah yeah like geo got man
hands look yeah if you guys won pictures
of me man over thousand dollar disease
what's you're working right yeah it's
not what I otherwise man hands you if
you guys want to use man hands
you're gonna interrupt 4000 bucks each
only I'm showing them off yeah what am i
doing
[Music]
you